we gotta talk about Haley and Andy yeah
officially together yeah Phil Dunphy
must be so happy about this I know Phil
Dunphy's so proud so proud he's like the
best dad ever
I know dream dinner dream dad you know
we're gonna play around with their
relationship you know they have very
different personalities kind of the
whole opposites attract it's not like a
Dylan Haley situation anymore to where
they're kind of just walking into walls
together anything on the show that Haley
hasn't done that you would just love to
see her tackle I've always had a dream
that Haley auditions for like a singing
competition show and she's tone deaf
that would be awesome I think that would
be so much fun but she thinks she's like
the next Brittany of course yeah
you know it's funny about that as I saw
on your Instagram that you got a guitar
for your birthday
from your boyfriend and you actually can
see I do sing but it's not like my main
priority but that's why I thought it
would be so funny that like if Haley was
tone-deaf would you ever on the side put
out some music of your own I do write
music that's why my boyfriend got me a
guitar because he's like I love your
music and you should be able to write
your own like compose your own music as
well I don't I don't know maybe it's if
I start getting bored during hiatus
during hiatus I don't I I've recorded
one song for a friend and it was a gift
for a friend I wrote it for her and I
gave it to her and her husband
but that's the only type of recording
that I've ever done other than like the
Annie soundtrack
I'm not ruling it out